[Music]
hi everyone my name is Ida I'm a product
manager on the Chrome OS team and
welcome to all of you to our session on
developing Android apps on Chrome OS now
we talked about this last year at i/o
and if you saw that talk today's talk is
a continuation we'll be talking about
the basics briefly and talking about how
we've worked with a number of you over
the past year and as well as sharing a
number of new features that we'd love to
tell you about so first of all let's
talk about why this matters so we've
talked previously about the success of
Chromebooks within the education space
where we outsell every other device
combines but Google's really been
doubling down on Chrome OS you've
hopefully been inundated by ads over q4
last year and ongoing this year and
that's helped drive demand in the
consumer space too so much so that in q4
last year 17% of notebooks sold in the
US for Chromebooks
so why does this matter to you Android
developers so the headline here is
Android apps work on Chrome OS how does
that happen
it works by the android framework
running inside a container that sits on
top of the base of Chrome OS and the
full Play stores are already available
so your app is probably already running
on Chrome OS now ultimately what we care
about is a good user experience part of
that is the operating system itself and
part of that is the apps that users
choose to run now we've been investing
heavily and improving the product and
those of you who use Chrome OS over the
past year have seen evidence of that and
system updates you've gotten and many of
you who are developing apps we've
already been working with to ensure that
you're ensuring that the apps work
really well on Chrome OS Adobe roblox
sony EA and many many more have already
include
Chromebook optimizations in their latest
updates on to the Play Store and that's
opening up different kinds of usage and
different kinds of revenue may Alan p.m.
from Evernote told us pencil book users
are spending four times more time in
Evernote than an average app user an
Andrew and David founders from steadfast
innovation who make the squid app told
us that Chromebooks have made up 21
percent of their revenue over the last
30 days so first of all to begin we were
quickly going to review some basics
ensuring that an app works well on
Chrome OS comes down to four key
differences between Chromebooks and
phones wider screens default landscape
window management and different primary
input devices keyboard pointer stylus
first wider screens chromic screens are
bigger from 10.1 inch on the smaller
side to 15 inch on some of our larger
units so apps need to be able to work
well at all of these works and respond
appropriately to resize events for
example a IDs coding lessons now switch
to a two column view when the app has
resized to be wider second default
landscape as a default landscape device
apps need to have a really great
landscape experience and so for example
pocket casts pins open its navigations
menu and arranges items in a grid so
they can fill the space available rather
than listing items out with white space
to the right third multi window chrome
OS is a multi window desktop environment
the sign easy and Sony sketch apps and
their latest versions on the Play Store
and now resizable so users can work
better with these inside our environment
and finally maybe the most important
keyboard and mouse inputs when a user
pulls out a laptop and uses it the
keyboard and touchpad are closest to the
user so they gravitate towards them as
their primary inputs so the infinite
painter team is an example built
keyboard accelerators for common
commands so users can get around fast
inside the interface and that's
especially true for games so pick Sonic
they make war robots built keyboard
controls into their game
the game now uses a special manifest
flag to get inputs directly from Chrome
OS and enables standard WASD gaming
controls so these are just a few of the
app teams who are now building and
testing their apps for Chrome OS and a
huge huge thank you to everyone many of
you are here in the audience that we've
worked with we're always looking for
apps that work really really great on
Chrome OS so that we can show them off
and we want your app to be one of them
now to talk about some of the latest
improvements in Chrome OS for Android
app developers I'd like to hand over to
Stephan one of our lead engineers on
Chrome OS please welcome Stephan
morning everyone I'm glad you could all
join for our today's talk and I'm here
to talk about well all our latest news
what we have done and what you can do in
order to improve your application even
more for a desktop environment so first
slide
what is new so that is one of the things
which is mostly important for the user
but of course also has some impact on
what you are doing and then ever unsink
so you can do we have added a lot of
stuff over the last year and we really
want to show that and we hope that you
are actually making best use of it and
last of it
best practices so when you are following
these best practices you will have a
better chance in the Play Store because
you will bubble up and we will make sure
of that so what's new let's see so first
off we have improved our tablet mode why
did we do that because we have now also
a tablet only device well and what did
we change
well there are smoother animations we
have removed the caption bar so means
the window control bar and the controls
from the caption control bar they are
actually now moving down into the shelf
as you can see there and also all
windows are automatically start at
fullscreen so which is of course
experience what you expect on each other
so next thing a split screen we have
added split screen which is well you
know that of course from phones but now
on a big tablet and or bigger screen it
makes of course much more sense so you
can split now the screen with any kind
of window which is available on Chrome
OS so it might be well might be a Chrome
window might be of course an Android we
know the only thing is at the moment you
will not be able to figure out that you
are actually running in split screen we
will headset later the next thing is you
have a the picture and picture so it's
the full specification according to
Android oh and it will coming soon and
you can resize a window you can explai
sit at multiple locations and it will be
fairly similar to the one which we are
using for web applications as well so we
have also added the Android keyboard so
you can essentially replace now
coming soon the the Chrome OS keyboard
with an android keyboard which makes a
lot of people happy notifications we
have overhauled our notifications they
are looking not now much more like so
color scheming and everything should be
much more integrated you have to chop
now instead of swiping and well
everything is much more integrated into
the Chrome OS style in itself and yeah
pro audio so we have actually added
since m65 beginning of this year em
that's all milestones I don't know if
you know that but it's essentially like
every six weeks we have a new release
cycle and m65 is out or a since a while
and MIDI is in since while in our pixel
book so and soon we will also have
multi-channel audio USB audio
multi-channel USB or a audio a audio
memory mapped and this is all coming
later this year and with that you have
actually seen when you were coming in
someone playing music here he was
actually using a pixel book and to show
you a little bit more about it I want to
invite for a RICO Testament from the
founder of algorithm to actually show
how this works
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so you have possibly seen how
everything was really real time
synchronized visit abayas
and everything is real time so it's
getting more interesting advanced things
now what you can do it to your
application in order to make your life
well to make the life on a desktop
better well become desktop native I
think I had that already last year but
we have of course a follow-up on that
one so first off this is something which
is something everybody knows for my
everyday business right menu
accelerators they're not really very
something special right but the thing is
like if you were using the toolkit UI in
the past it was actually from a I think
it was like I don't know angel cake or
whatever Android was back then so means
like really ancient so this play was
small and they had to actually fit
everything on there and it looked ugly
it was really not not meant to be
primetime so we have actually changed
library to make this much much easier
for you to actually get these kind of
things in so and all you have to do is
you have to go into your layout XML you
use in your menu you put into the item
itself then the shortcut means the
character and modifier keys and you're
ready to go well not entirely but if
you're using a standard menu you have to
actually call then the set Queerty
what was it again set creative mode to
true so that you are actually getting
alphanumeric characters okay this is
really old but it's still there so shelf
integration that is something like if
you want to do something inside the
shelf you want to change your icon like
for example you're opening a document or
whatnot you want to change the shape of
the icon itself or you want to display
then the document which you have opened
you can actually do that with this set
task description very simple and very
effective next thing is if you want to
combine multiple items inside the
shelves into one menu item you can
actually put in my intent put extra you
put then the shelf shortcut to it and
you take then any kind of string for a
kind of modifier which you actually know
and you actually then reuse it for all
the items you want to put into the same
same episode cuts are coming so this is
something which is coming soon it's
there already since I think n mr1 and we
will support them very soon as well
so essentially you can actually actions
and any kind of short things which you
want to do in order to to get the user
faster access to things the back button
well I think many of you since you are
already doing something for our Chrome
OS have already seen that there's a back
button up in the window control bar well
you have also a back button we know that
and the problem is of course two on top
of each other looks pretty crappy so
therefore by adding this special meter
flag you can get rid of it makes it much
much nicer and that helps but there's
one other thing and this is I think even
more important if you're on a desktop
and you're pressing backspace or escape
or navigate back or whatnot and your
windows suddenly disappears is something
which is very unexpected to the user
please don't do that so if you can do it
please what you should do is you should
actually check if your activity is at
the bottom of well at the root of the
stack and if it is and you know that
your windowed please don't close your
window please keep it open because it's
really really unexpected and disturbing
froze users suddenly all his work is
suddenly gone lifetime management so we
are getting a lot of requests from from
users which said well you know what my
application isn't really running
multitasking well why is it not
multitasking well because the thing is
like I have this game I'm playing
and I'm also checking my new status and
the new status isn't updating while I'm
playing but I would really like to see
that well they are actually three states
there's running there's paused and
they're stopped running and post means
you are visible on the screen so which
means not that you should actually drop
everything and stop that when you're
getting a pause no you can actually
continue to run unless you are high
whatever game where you have to have a
lot of real-time action and whatnot
where you maybe want to really pause
in most cases you really want to
continue running so please do this and
you make a lot of users much much
happier
next thing sharing data well I said
already earlier that we have plenty of
windows on our desktop right so there
are all kinds of Chrome OS your window
and whatnot if you don't specify drag
flick global and you are doing a drag
and drop operation it will not be
dropped on another application this is
an only for you so in order to allow
other applications to actually get your
data please specify this flag and if you
are actually getting some data from
someone well also check out what you are
getting if you are simply blindly taking
text
well you might actually miss out of all
the richness of the data which comes
with it so therefore please check that
out as well
and if you're looking at the clipboard
it's exactly the same thing you
definitely want to have of course all
the richness of whatever is being copied
and pasted as well so with that resizing
I was talking last year about resizing
that it's a really big problem right
because resizing looks pretty clunky on
Android in general when you are doing
this so here is a solution for you this
is an application which was written for
material design 2.0 and it looks nice on
a phone see this looks actually pretty
nice so when you are doing when you're
following the design study from from
material design they were coming up with
this thing for a tablet form factor
see there's more information you can
actually see more things and they are
revealing more stuff so with that let me
show you a short demo of my notebook
so so there's the application and you
can resize it and as you can see while
I'm resizing it more and more data as IG
coming into play and see more stuff is
coming oops
let what of course the wrong guy yeah
there you go and you see that more and
more data is coming in this is all
dynamically happening and it's very
fluid without a restart which is usually
the problem right can I back to my
slides please so first off good news the
demo is actually online you can download
it you can test it all yourself it's on
github and there's also an excellent
code lab which is actually even showing
more so you can also doing animations
while you're transforming from one
layout into another which is then
looking really cool you should check out
the code lab for sure
so how is it being done well first off
you need to have a constrained layout
state file it's like a blueprint which
is essentially getting all the different
layouts into into some kind of order
when to use which one and then comes the
tricky part every of these layouts need
to have all UI elements which you use so
if you don't want to see you if you want
to show it then you simply hide the
thing if it's hidden it doesn't show but
it's still in the layout itself so one
by doing this and in oncreate you will
actually create then the transition in
which you want to use when you want to
transition from one to another and you
set the unconstraint changed layout
handler you will be able to do to attend
the the pre-layout change handler which
is then essentially like giving the
control to the to the to the sorry which
is giving the control to our layout and
which is doing the transition itself so
inside your activity what you have to do
is you have to add the on configuration
change handler which is usually being
called every time when something changed
like the virtual keyboard is
disconnected the screen resolution
changes or anything like that and fine
well and from there you are essentially
calling the constraint changed layout
Handler to actually let him know what
the size is and that will actually and
do all the work for you and finally you
will actually add inside the Android
manifest file the requests that you want
to handle all configuration changes for
size changes and with that you are done
if you want to try it out again try the
code lab to actually get this done so
the next thing is new well zero latency
Inc what does zero latency Inc means
well you have possibly had already a pen
you were trying to draw something and
you see there is a lag between drawing
something or using the pen and seeing
something on the on the device itself so
where is it coming from well first off
you have to read the sender you have to
do the input processing you have to then
do the app code whatever the application
is doing you have to do some drawing
with OpenGL and you're actually doing
multiple buffering because you have to
actually pass everything to the
compositor which is in compositing
actually everything on the Chrome OS
side or whatever you're parading system
you have the compositing side and it's
going through the entire pipeline which
might be for for images or whatnot so in
total you are coming out to a hundred
milliseconds of delay which is very very
noticeable so the ideal thing is of
course you simply remove all the
compositing so now we are down to well
of roughly two frames which is less than
sorry two milliseconds right
so but if we are adding now also the
prediction logic to it well then we are
really at pretty much zero so mission
accomplished so and with that I will
actually hand it over to Powell Riviere
a comic book author which is showing us
a whole thing in action
thank you hi everyone hmm
all right can you guys see what I got up
there so I drew some spider-man that's
typically what I'm known for at Marvel
but I also do with a nose did anyone see
infinity war yet all right I did - all
right so what I like about this app is
you know you can rotate you can draw at
any angle you can also do layers this is
a infinite painter by the way so what
I've done is I've drawn Spidey ahead of
time and I'm going to ink on top of him
using some of the inking tools oh I
gotta change my color
I'm from the school of thought where
spider-man should have expressive eyes
and so I'm glad that they did that in
the movies
some people don't like doing the webbing
but I do it does add a little bit of
time to each panel but it's worth it in
the end
and then of course you can add color as
well I put in a layer already with a red
base and I'm gonna add some shadow to it
one of the other features I like about
this so you can double tap to reset it
and then if you hold and long press
it'll flip it so as a comic book artists
I'm always flipping things if I can
because it gives you a fresh perspective
of course there's all kinds of drawing
tools that you can use some are more
painterly than others
and what I did was I clipped the shadow
layer to the layer beneath it which
means that everything I do on this layer
will be bounded by the layer below it
one way to save time
and of course the other nice thing about
the stylus is it has tilt so in this
case I made tilt depending on which way
I hold the pen it will give me a thick
or thin line
No
I could do this all day I usually do
usually this there aren't this many
people watching while I'm drawing
y'all are lucky I'm even wearing pants
and let's finish it off with some spidey
sense because Thanos is nearby
and he's a Malthusian
there we go thank you Thanks
it's hi thanks
okay so how is it done so we have an ink
overlay view which is a new thing which
is not yet really public if you want to
get access to it there's a QR code
please grab it and sign up for our our
release so it will actually be edit then
to our release notes as soon as we are
giving you access to it so but
essentially we have well you can see the
code and it might change a little bit so
multi display which is another topic so
it's a very big topic because the thing
is like on the phone you have two
screens right you have the internal
screen you have an external screen maybe
on a well if you're really creative and
you have a pixel book Pro you might
actually get up to seven screens I'm not
entirely sure I thought that is possible
so anyways but the thing is like what
does it mean for you well actually it
means a lot because the thing is like
many applications are doing stupid
things sorry you are not that right but
the thing is like for example simply
using hey I want to get to display the
display information for display id0
well which is a default display right
well the thing is like it's not the
default display because what is the
default display you don't know that
right so therefore we have actually if
you are prio then we are thinking that
you are a non multi aware multi display
aware application in this case we have a
special thing for you to make your life
easier essentially zero is like a
virtual display which is always a
display you are on so and therefore the
entire API is is really clear everything
is exactly as it should be but the thing
is like you get this kind of special
display so that you're working fine if
however on the other hand you are
actually something after all or oh then
you will actually get a different
treatment in that case you will get the
real IDs the real display IDs so
therefore if you are doing these kind of
things you should be careful what you
are doing so and yes one additional
thing is if you are actually running an
NYC application you still have the set
launch display
as a function call so what should you do
well you should definitely use the the
size of the window so always use your
context and try to get this as the
display matrix from that that is
everything perfectly for you so and if
you want to see any kind of changes like
for example you were moved to a
different display or something like then
look at on configuration change to see
these kind of changes and if you want to
actually position yourself think also
about settings the set launch display ID
if you do not want to get to the same
screen where your current application is
on what you shouldn't do is you
shouldn't really assume anything well
without using your context if you're
using any kind of display ID I mean
trying to get the default display you
will get something which is most
certainly wrong so and also what was
that yeah don't don't make any
assumptions that you are actually on the
built-in display because that is
definitely wrong as well and last but
not least don't assume that you're
always running from the same display so
presentation API we were being asked to
actually get this to you we are getting
that very soon and it is
well actually I think by pretty much by
now it should be there
you can alternatively also you set
launch display ID and set launch bounds
which will actually do pretty much the
same same sweetie and caming so what is
they up so basically we have Vulcan
support for four examples that picks the
book it was actually shipping already
1.0 was a shipping beginning of this
year one point one should be shipping
around now and older I take just are
also on the way so working as much
faster them and so on so when you are
building your own game one so there are
a few things what you should actually
take care of first off you should always
use the latest version of the framework
if you're using unity and whatnot they
are actually fixing their stuff so if
for example a windows size changes and
whatnot and they as the input region
which is changing a little bit they will
actually fix that for you so please use
the latest run because otherwise you
vacation will fail when you are trying
to be resized so next thing is also use
int'l either 64-bit or so a 2 bit native
code as well don't use only arm because
arm is of course a little bit slower
especially on the high end devices so
when you are running a game application
quality control might actually be bad
for you depending on what you are doing
so if you have for example multiple
surfaces and whatnot and you're trying
then to to squeeze all the latest thing
and if you're running into a state where
you are using suddenly quadruple
buffering because you're being composite
on the desktop or something your quality
control might actually do something
negative to your quality and you get
some kind of really weird behavior so
therefore try it out on Chromebooks
before you before you release it that
would be really awesome and yeah if
you're using a lot of layers like a lot
of surface use and whatnot you might
also fall out of this and then your
quality might actually drop so therefore
if you can actually do everything in one
in a single layer and said please try to
do that instead and always be aware that
your window size might change at any
point in time and of course since users
for example minimizing you you might
actually lose your state and or if the
window gets being resized the state
might actually be lost so please save
your state best practices as I said
earlier we are trying to work with
Playstore to actually serve face
applications which are really good for
the Chrome OS environment so therefore
if you are doing everything which we are
asked for you will actually get a better
rating so therefore target SDK bigger
than 26 that is definitely something
good implement keyboard/mouse
active and mouse navigation that is a
good thing
UI elements when you're resizing they
should always be inside the screen so
because if you're all tabbing through
something and suddenly your element is
outside of the screen that's bad when
you're doing resizing definitely try to
think about landscape and portrait those
operations are very important make good
use of a lot of space because you have a
lot of space so
use it I showed you how to use a
high-tech chiral components whenever
possible in order to save your state or
save interest a plus that's also a
little same thing be fluid and please
the won't crash let us really the worst
thing which can happen check out that
you are not crashing and with that I'm
passing it on to Emily who is talking
about all the great tools we have for
you thank you there's so many exciting
new things for Android applications on
Chrome OS and I'm honored to be able to
present to you three new amazing
developer tools to help optimizing your
application for Chrome OS faster and
easier the first one I'm you've all been
very patient so thank you for your
patience and a big thank you to the
engineering team for making this happen
and doing it right in Android studio
we're pleased to present the Chrome OS
emulator
[Applause]
so right in Android studio you have a
full Chrome OS image you can test out
the user flow for Chrome OS and of
course test and optimize your app for
Android your Android application right
in Chrome OS which is awesome however if
any of you have ever made an Android
application that's my joke okay some of
you did some of you made one if you do
you'll know there's nothing like testing
on a real device especially a form
factor like this where the user will be
flipping and rotating it tossing it on
the bed keyboard input mouse input MIDI
controllers stylus input you just you
need to test this on a real device so
we've made that a lot easier I'm very
happy to present ADB debugging over us
beating it's available for your pixel
book in your HP Chromebook X to the
public documentation will be out in a
week or two so please watch those links
and more devices coming soon and it
makes development that much easier okay
so I said there was three exciting
developer tools we're printing
announcing and the first two are awesome
but I actually think the third one is
even more exciting and I truly truly
believe it's gonna knock your socks off
and we didn't want anyone to go home
with cold feet so we brought some
replacement socks for when they fly off
your your feet here's some and if you're
in the middle of the audience or at the
back don't be jealous
there's plenty of socks for everyone and
on your way out of the session you can
you can pick them up we're gonna have
people handing them out so with that yes
socks right socks is your new developer
tool so I'm gonna switch over to the
Chromebook for a quick demo we have a
terminal super-exciting terminal you can
see get clone all sorts of exciting
things I cloned the codelab
optimizing your Android application for
Chrome OS which you should check out at
the code lab tent there's dinosaurs but
what's interesting about this particular
terminal is it's running inside a full
Linux environment no clap okay you watch
the keynote you watch the keynote okay
fine so if you
have a full Linux environment you can
cut for this next one you can install an
application Linux application like
Android studio so here we have Android
studio it more exciting than a terminal
I guess so here I have the code lab
loaded up I'm making those dinosaurs
click I'm adding drag-and-drop and I go
in here run oh so if you're in the back
and you can't see that says Google pixel
book which means when I press ok you
know goes through the Gradle build Oh
pushing the application to the device
what on device yeah look you can click
oh we got keyboard commands and that's
it's pushed it straight to the device so
we can program on the pixel book in
Android studio push directly to the
device test your app out and of course
you have your logcat there with and all
your debugging tools so this is amazing
and it's so glad the engineering team
let me present this super exciting
announcement so we're super excited by
linux on Chromebooks we're gonna tell
you how to set it up for yourself before
I do we had a lot of questions at office
hours and in the code lab what's going
on behind the scenes how does this work
how's that set up so I'm gonna give you
a brief overview
here's Chrome OS in real life it's a bit
snazzier but it's a representative box
and inside there we have the Android
container this is nothing new this is
how your Android apps run on Chrome OS
today of course what is the new is we
have Linux VM and we install great
applications like tux tracer which they
wouldn't let me show today also Android
studio and to achieve that last step
which i think is the most exciting
pushing straight to the app and
debugging on device we need to connect
ADB to the Android container do that's
quite simple ADB connect command it's
not a secret IP address it's the IP
address for the ad ADB D on the Android
container and this will be in the public
it is in the public instructions already
but here's a
tip since he came to our session for
some situations is handy to set up a
little SSH tunnel simple SSH tunnel in
Chrome OS that will just forward those
connections automatically not necessary
it's helpful in some situations here's
the instructions if you haven't whoops
here are the instructions if you haven't
seen it I think we were number one on
hacker news yesterday or something so
that's kind of exciting please install
it on your Google pixel book coming to
more devices soon we're super excited
about it let us know how it works try it
out so where are we at we have an
emulator we have a TB debugging over USB
we've got Linux on Chromebooks running
Android studio which you can debug and
develop on the device and you have socks
for those long cold coding nights so
your Tootsie's stay toasty what's
missing nothing right except I heard a
rumor on the way in but some of you
don't yet have a pixel book what so
we're gonna help you out a little bit
with that
on your way out when you grab your socks
you can pick up
[Applause]
a coupon for 75% off Oh Google picks the
book
don't forget your socks oh they're
kicking me out the stage so I'm going to
say quickly come to our code labs we
have two great code labs you can do the
resizing with animations it looks great
you can make keyboard input
drag-and-drop click on the dinosaurs
talk to us office hours today fill out
the survey thank you can everyone come
back on stage it's about we're done yes
Shahid federico come on up Stepan Paulo
thank you thank you so much
[Music]